[Music]
all those in favor please say
the country carried i know sitting down
the back we've got the mir
and philip redmond it's nice to have you
both here conflicts of interest
sorry apologies uh mr chair i had
preferred an
apology to you to leave early at 9 00 pm
okay thank you
and we'll include that if you're happy
with that yeah we'll include that
conflicts of interest
it would be appropriate you don't take
part in that discussion yeah thank you
that's appropriate confirmation minutes
are there any corrections to the minutes
appear to be none someone prepared to
move the adoption of those
moved by jason second to duncan put that
all those in favor please say aye
country carried any matters arising
appear to be none reputations and
presentations
and what we would have the this now
and then we'll take the item 6.2
while sam redmond's still here because
that's dealing with the
dudley parks it makes sense to take them
on so
all right then if you'd like to come
forward sam let's
welcome you both here it's
good to have you with us
if you could introduce us yeah yeah good
evening everyone
my name's sam redman i'm the youth
development facilitator as part of the
community team at the
council and with me i have uh ruby
wilson who's one of our
youth council members and she's here to
kind of
help me out when i have any gaps in
memory so yeah really great to be here
thanks for
for having us um really we're here to
present to you the
uh report which i am going to take
largely as read but in regard to the
waimakariri youth council dudley park
redevelopment
project um a bit of a mouthful but
basically uh youth council were granted
some funds uh through the annual plan to
look into consultation and eventually
installation of some features to enhance
the uh the dudley park area around the
skatepark
they've had a little bit of progress on
that they've done some consultation
and now we're here to
[Music]
update you all on what's happening and
also just noting
that we would love to have a
representative from the board as part of
the
project group which the youth council
formed so
yeah apart from that
the recommendations and apart from that
summary that's about what i have to say
but would welcome any questions
that the board has for either of us so
we deal with 6.2
now at the same time we'll deal with 6.2
at the same time i think that's
what really sam spoken to so if you look
at
it on pages 43 to 81 um
we're dealing with that report kirsten
thank you seaman ruby and welcome
we noted that with covert 19 the skate
jam was cancelled so we couldn't have
any face-to-face engagement there as you
mentioned
um and that was done online were you
planning a face-to-face engagement now
that we're
hopefully at back at level 1 in the
subsequent consultation
yeah i think absolutely that has to be a
priority um
for us you know we youth council did
what they could over the
over the uh uh obviously the lockdown
and everything
in terms of doing some online stuff but
i don't think you can beat the face to
face really
and so wanting to maybe do a skate jam
again
fingers crossed with that event can
continue um
and also consulting with neighbors and
existing park users
face to face ideally if we can
and that will be around updated plans
based on
this last round of consultation
further questions of sam
joan with
skatepark um what is the security like
for the young people
um so that they're um they're protected
and that there's no
um adverse or nefarious
things happening around for the security
of the young people
yeah i suppose that's um that's a really
important question i think it gets to
the heart of what the project
really is about which is about creating
a more community
friendly space a place where anyone from
the community can be
um can feel safe you know and
there is evidence to suggest that having
that um intergenerational approach to a
to an area
is is is is good for that kind of thing
yeah
subsequent one so what steps are in
place to
monitor the security of the children
skating at the park
as far as i know and i don't know for
sure but
i don't know of any specific security
measures that are in place um had a
couple of conversations with the police
and they are sometimes called down to
the skate park but i don't think there's
anything that is an ongoing
provision at this stage
any further questions if not we have
some
recommendations there come back to you
monique
and when when we get to moving it
remember that
that they're seeking a representative
and that's c and their recommendations
right monique
that's all right i was gonna ask looking
at your design
are you um i was just curious a few
things about it is that all right
absolutely yeah i look like your solar
charging seat
does it work if someone sits on it
that's a that's a great question
no i'm just curious i i don't know a
huge amount about them these these were
some ideas the youth council i think
brainstormed and kind of threw around to
see what would hit would fit and green
space recommended some ideas
um we've not done a huge amount of
research into what how they how they
work just yet
but at the moment it's not something
that we like sorry can you use the mic
it's very hard
um at the moment it's not something that
we've looked into as a
definite option that we're going to do
but it's definitely like an idea out
there but
it's not a step that we've put out to be
taken soon yeah
right okay and a few more things like
those
are you going to have artificial grass
on these hump things you've got there
for seating so yes that's so that's
another
point that we we're still um um figuring
out
i think based on the last round of
consultation um the mounted seating was
um there were a lot of fans of that idea
um
it'll depend on budget i think what what
that looks like there's some really cool
ones um in christchurch at the margaret
mayhe
park that yes that could fit really well
but we need to investigate pricing and
all that kind of thing right
okay and i was thinking your area is
really tiny that you're allowed to work
in
i wonder if the council might consider
letting you have a bit more space
because it's such a tiny it's a tiny
spot but anyway especially if you're
thinking maybe along the lines of a
playground
or bigger stuff as well there's really
no room to put
much there did you want to say anything
to that ruby um we have been talking
about that um because we were
wanting to put in something that would
kind of include the younger children
around because
mate obviously making it a more
community friendly we want to
be able to have all ages they're not
just like we don't want five-year-olds
skating with the
14 year olds and being run into or
something and so we
have been looking at trying to figure
out a way to have like a playground or
some sort of play area for the younger
children
but yeah thank you and i think a big a
big
part of the project is obviously limited
funding so
wanting to inspire further work down
down the road and so we
uh the project group have identified
kind of three
um three big big things which were the
seating
and um what else do we have ruby you
might have to help me out
the seating the a barbecue and
um some kind of kids area and then
recommendations for the future if things
could continue yeah okay
thank you any further questions
we have a recommendation that someone
prepared to
move something and nominate a member or
does any member like to be on
on that working party with the youth
council monique wood there we are
so is someone prepared to
jason you're moving the recommendation
with monique
okay we're segmented by paul do you wish
to speak to it
no poor
yeah i think it's a good project and i
think monique will fill the role
pretty good for it anyone else
all right i'll put the recommendation
all those in favor please say aye
to the country declare it carried thanks
sam and ruby for coming along and keep
up your good work with the youth council
so
that's that's good thanks for having us
thank you
right we move now to item 6.1
flexton road pages 1942
something that the board's moderately
familiar with this
and don you've got a recommended
addition or change to your
recommendations um
emma would you like to borrow paul's
mike and read it out we'll just let the
board know what you're
suggesting okay so there's a new
recommendation
that will come in between b and
um c will go to d so the recommendation
is now um isn't a sea
recommends a new sea recommends to the
council
that it removes the kerbin channel at
the northern end of the western roadside
to allow consideration of informal
parking
noting the rsa has expressed concern
regarding this
and noting the work will be tended with
the kerbin channel included
thank you thank you with the
clarification that the rsa means road
safety audit not
returns
thanks don that's quite useful
[Laughter]
road safety order okay now we've
clarified this not that
thank you just for clarity that's a new
c
and everything slips down one that's
correct
all right don uh thank you mr chair the
the this um has been in front of you on
a number of occasions
can you use your mic don sorry it's it's
not that easy to hear
number of occasions previously the major
change
which you will have noted from the last
time we spoke to you on this
is that unfortunately we've needed to
take
out the reference to a shared path
the the provisions that are necessary
around a shared path are significantly
higher
than a footpath and
to try as we might we were unable to
come up with a a
framework that really allowed
that to be installed in the room we have
and it became clear that something
needed to give so
i think you'll be well aware that fraser
in particular has
bent over backwards to look at a range
of different options to try and fit
everything in
we thought we had a solution by shifting
to the east
but it became clear again through our
road safety auditing process
that the only way we could make the
roads safe uh the
eastern foot the eastern shed path safe
would have been effectively to remove
all parking from the eastern side
the site distance is required for it to
be a shared path
were such that there was really no um
parking left so when faced with that as
the stark reality
we have come back to you recommending uh
that the
footpath that we put install a footpath
rather than a shared path we have had
the opportunity to discuss that briefly
with some of the
businesses and generally it has
got support we're well aware though that
we have only spoken to
some of the affected parties
and there will be many cyclists out
there who are disappointed in this
decision
but on balance it was something we felt
was the only way really forward the most
recent change that we have here is
to allow further opportunity to consider
some degree of informal parking at the
northern end
but we have noted that that still does
need to get through the hurdles of a
road safety audit
one possible solution is that if the
price the tender price does come in
significantly under then potentially
we could use some of that money to
assist to
make for instance put retaining
structure or or
something on that length of the drain to
allow us more space
to allow a more safer parking area there
but in the meantime we're really just
allowing parking to take place here
rather than
well this this would leave it open to
that option
uh we as staff would still recommend
that no
parking be up there allowed up there but
we're aware that that would be a very
uh unpopular decision and so in order to
give you
a solution that possibly will work we've
come up with this additional
recommendation for you to consider
um fraser uh may well have some
additional points he wants to add
appraiser um just with reference to any
cycle facility although although no
specific provision for cyclists has been
made
staff have considered alternative
options uh for integrating the wider
south brook area
into the rangiora cycle network one
option
could be to construct a new facility
from the proposed flax and fern siding
intersection along fernside road with
potential connections to the
passchendaele track via the new daniel
smith development
and links into rangiora via south belt
and townsend road
and i think don's pretty much covered
everything off on the parking front
right i also acknowledge uh
the fact that we had a discussion you
invited
paul as portfolio
holder and the mayor and myself to a
briefing to discuss the way forward i
appreciate that
earlier on right questions joan
i'm just going back to um the western
side and and the drain running along
there oops we need someone to put the
lights on
um i understand that this still needs to
be some additional reparation work
in there because the of the the perhaps
the vulnerability of it
of some part of it collapsing is that
true
and to enable parking parking on the
western side
to enable a parking
facility that we were comfortable to say
met appropriate parking standards yes
you're correct
and so that's not what is this
recommendation is really
putting in front of you it's just
effectively leaving
the curbing out which would allow people
to park there
there would be room for cars to park but
there is not
room for a footpath for instance for
them to safely move along that side
and then cross the road to the eastern
side where there is a footpath
so it is not something that ticks
all of the boxes we would normally
require to detect
before we allocated a formal parking
area
so if we were to formalize that more it
would require
some sort of retaining structure that's
not part of the recommendation in front
of you at the moment it's just allowing
that option to
potentially be progressed so is that
likely to occur
as you develop down there is there is
likely to be extra costs incurred in
securing and
making secure the drain on the western
side down there just to allow
um for
for parking or for the road
if passed if the resolutions as put in
front of you
are passed we will be installing a curb
up the majority of the western side
which would eliminate parking
and for parking in the future to be
allowed on the western side would mean
pulling out that curb and channel
so that is something the council may
consider in for instance
20 years it's probably not something
they would consider in say
three or four or five years so if this
is passed as is in front of you now
there will be no parking on the western
side
that is not to limit councils as i say
not to limit council's future
decision-making
the exception is when we say at the
northern end we're effectively meaning
between the last
driveway heading north so there is
around probably around about 10
car parks we can fit in there which will
not be widening or
strengthening we would just be allowing
people to continue to do what they do
now
which is to pull on to that verge
right um yeah it's just um
i understand that you know on that
eastern side there's these huge
um power poles this is a question yes it
will be
um mitigate um mitigate
the widening of it to a cycle way so so
there's no other option really apart
from
um going to the the west side and
in covering the channel which of course
is more costs is that correct
that there are two other options which
again as staff we didn't consider
were the right outcome the first would
be that we remove the parking on the
eastern side would allow a shared path
down there
the second would be we do away with the
central median
which the feedback right from the start
of our consultation process
has indicated that a central median is
uh a key
part of whatever upgrade that local
community would like to see there the
the the ability to turn right either on
or off
flaxton road is a key part of what the
businesses are looking for
so yes there are certainly options of
using that
minimal space in different ways but it
would mean giving up
something like either the parking or the
central median to achieve it
any further questions thank you for that
i'm not cursed
kirsten then duncan
don looking looking through your risks
and and stakeholders consulted
you've noticed businesses you've noticed
keep your beautiful you've got the water
zone committee there's a
whole list here where are the road users
in this submission list who come from
silver stream and mandeville and ahoka
and
those areas in terms of this quite
dramatic change to school cycles to not
have a dedicated
cycling facility they haven't been
consulted
uh and effectively i think it is a
reflection of the
time frame we have available to us this
money
will end come into june
the time frame we're on now is already
as you'll see from your recommendations
we are tendering
next week and not actually waiting for
the council
meeting prior to going to tinder with
the potential risk that if the council
disagrees
with our current approach then we would
be withdrawing the tender at that stage
and accepting the consequence of that
decision
but this has been right really from the
start a very very tight time frame to
achieve
and unfortunately we haven't been able
to achieve i guess all of the
elements we might like to have otherwise
built around a project like this
bearing in mind that the council has a
sustainability strategy and
you talk about that that we have an aim
for good linkage and active
travel options how will this be seen in
the community as
almost going backwards to areas of not
progressing cycle lands
how do you believe this will be
perceived
i think there will certainly be an
element of the community who will be
disappointed
and see this as a backwards step um
i would potentially suggest that and i
think
fraser has used the terminology a few
times that effectively we're trying to
fit a 20
meter corridor into 16 meters
and so we have right from the start very
limited space
with regard to the cycleway being the
thing that has
gone we believe that is probably the
best
of the elements that could
have disappeared from the design and i
think as fraser said
there are opportunities for potentially
other routes
other than south other than flaxton road
the main argument against that is that
the people in flaxton road itself may be
cyclists as well
but if you were for instance traveling
down flaxton road
once you get to the roundabout you'll be
on a very difficult
well not a very difficult you'll be on a
road which is not
well suited for cyclists
and we have line side road not far away
with passchendaele
the roundabout will cater for cyclists
this design that you will see in front
of you does have pedestrian
access between the flexton
urban area um the south brook urban
southbrook industrial area
and the flexton fernside roundabout
which we are hopeful that as land
becomes developed
along that length we would look to
widening that and extending that
cycle way if that was going to improve a
link
and one option for it to do that would
be to zigzag it out through
the current resource recovery park out
to passchendale and link up there
but either way probably fernside
east could well be a link which gets
developed into the future to link
between
flexton fernside and lionside
we do a hundred percent appreciate this
is not ideal which is why you will have
seen
three four or five versions of this plan
come back to you which
attempted to fit it all in but
unfortunately we have
that brick wall where something has to
give could could this
this group actually make a
recommendation add it to the motion that
an investigation into an alternative
cycle could
uh be undertaken by staff would that be
possible
that would certainly be possible and in
fact maybe something you
you do want to do and i would remind the
board
um from its well boards briefing it
received relatively recently that there
is a cycle network plan currently being
developed
which will be coming to the board and to
the council
in coming months as
being suitable for consultation and then
there will be widespread community
consultation following on from that
so they are exactly the types of
opportunities that
i would encourage this board to utilise
to
to make comment for the council's
benefit duncan
um don to the best of my ability i've
tried to listen to your rationale
regarding the western parking issue
and you're obviously at the very top end
allowing ken people
parks is the wording and eye creep then
your recommendations um notes that no
informal parking be proposed
good point thank you for pointing that
yes out was getting confused indeed
incorrect now if with this latest one
coming in so that'll come out
don thank you we'll take i out of that
okay everything
okay it's monique and then joan
i see that a um uh cafe there
suggested that you have short-term
parking 10-15 minute parking
on are you considering like limiting the
parking on the roadside
to you know keep things moving so people
working there will
presumably pack offs off the street
yes we have discussed that both with uh
with submitters and also internally we
certainly are considering it but we do
know that it is a completely different
process which would require resolution
of council and there's a there's a
formal parking
by-law which would need amending in
order to achieve that so it's not
something
we're putting on the table at this stage
but it is certainly something we would
hope
would be considered to allow that
short-term customer parking rather than
all-day
staff parking joan
just a thought um i think sorry is it
question
yes it is
um i remember and you can correct me
or not please my question is am i
correct when we
went through the nzta when it was
scooters
and walking on on pathways and
cycling on pathways that that it was
agreed
that people could travel on a on a
almost on a walkway at no
more than 15 kilometers per hour am i
right or wrong
to clarify um there is a proposal by the
current government
to declare or to to make a new
ruling uh which is called accessible
streets
and if passed that will allow
some degree of usage of that footpath it
is still
uncertain exactly how far that will
extend
some commentators on that
would like to see it limited to children
only rather than
adults etc but it is uncertain where
that will fall
if it does fall open slather
that all cycles and and those matters
can use scooters can use the footpath
that wouldn't change what we're
recommending you do
it potentially would just allow another
avenue
for those using flexton road to
potentially remove themselves one step
for us to however declare it as i said
before for us to declare it a shared
path
would raise another level of compliance
issues which
we couldn't get to but if that law comes
through that would then just
allow the use of that footpath with no
extra work from us
okay further questions no further
questions
just before someone moves it just just
get emma again to remind us
of the change and that will include
taking out
i as well
at the northern end of the western
roadside to allow consideration of
informal parking noting the road safety
order has expressed concern
regarding this and noting the work will
be tended with the curb and channel
included
and then it goes on and i is removed yes
so
they all slip down when an eye goes all
right so
someone prepared to move
move by paul seconded by robbie
do you wish to speak to paul
i just think it needs to be um
people are anxiously waiting for it to
happen so the sooner it happens now the
um the better
we've probably done the best we can out
of a um
the width we can do so well done
thank you rob
kirsten i'd like to move an amendment
just in addition to the motion please
um that we request staff to investigate
an
alternative cycling route uh to connect
with the passenger path
so that that'll become a new whenever it
is at the bottom
so you just need a second if we're
second for that
andy okay just quickly speaking to that
um i'm
i understand we're between a rock and a
hard a hard place on this one
it is a narrow corridor for a very very
important route
we have to get it right um it's really
vital
that the the parking the turning is is
protected because it is a major traffic
therapy for us
however i think we'd be sending the
wrong signal if we didn't indicate
that we think cycling is really really
important in this area
we had a submission to the rangara town
center hearing
um specifically about this for people
coming from ahoka mandible area
and with the transition to e-bikes it
makes it a lot more accessible for
people to actually
even those who aren't super fit to
actually use cycles
and we need to encourage as it said good
linkages and active travel options going
forward it's one of our policies
so just by adding this it means that we
are seriously looking at another option
and it may mean that we may have to
accelerate that option to try and make
that work
but i appreciate the the speed and the
time frame
that you're under and it's a very
important piece of work
and did you wish to add to it no the
amendment's open for discussions
any discussion
i'll support the the the amendment um
the board member barnett's quite right
there was a submission
with regard to accessing by way of cycle
however um i i would dread to think that
this would in any way shape or form
um delay the the project
as it as it stands in the substantive
motion and i don't think it will so on
that basis i'm prepared to support it
with the
the understanding that yes staff can
investigate
but not ancillary work on top of this
and uh but we do need to have our eyes
wide
amendment agrees with you there too so
that's the board's position that's not
to hold up
the balance right i'll put the amendment
all those in favor please say aye
the country carried clear it carried we
now
come back to the new new motion all
anyone exercise the right reply happy
all right i'll put the motion
all those in favor please say i contrary
clear carried
we've dealt with 6.2 so we'll move on
thank you don
we'll move on to 6.3 the ashley street
car park
in new world lease simon
pages 82 to 87.
thank you mr chair and good evening
board members
i see you have a very large agenda
tonight so i won't
read it word for word essentially the
report in front of you
proposes that new world uh here in
rangiuro
would uh pay for an extension or sorry a
reconfiguration of the ashley street car
park which sits directly to the east of
the supermarket
that reconfiguration would produce two
car parks that's the maximum amount of
car parks a reconfiguration of that car
park
could actually produce uh with them
doing that and paying for that
they would then like to lease from us
those two car parks that are created to
provide click and collect services
for their customers there are a number
of
good reasons in the report stated for
why click and collect is good and and
you'll all be familiar with the
contactless arrangements since covered
so that's one very good reason
the other good reason is in addition to
creating two new car parks so us not
losing any car parks
you'll find that their occupancy rate
will actually be
higher so a lot of the customers of new
world not only use the new world car
park to the north but of course
the council's car park to the east and
that's why we have some trolley bays
in that car park to prevent trolleys
being left in our car parking spaces
new would have told us that in a
supermarket such as this the average
turnover of a customer is around 20
minutes
but with the contactless click and
collect it's more like five minutes
so in addition to producing the two new
car parks most well
a percentage of their customers will
start to use
uh those car parks and be more frequent
turnover therefore reducing the impact
on our own car parks as well
so we think that it's a it's a positive
move it increases the level of service
that we have from the supermarket in our
central town centre it doesn't have an
impact
on our car parking supply if anything it
improves occupancy very slightly
and it doesn't have a cost to council so
hence we're recommending that the
council
ah sorry that the community board uh
approved this report uh more than happy
to take any questions that
community board members might have paul
yeah these two car parks were leasing
proposed at least to a new world
they if things change
um they'll be still parking restrictions
on it they won't be able to use it for a
um
all-day parking is that correct yes very
good question
so you'll note some conditions in the
report that we would use as parameters
for a lease
certainly they would have to use it for
click and click services only
uh we would also include some out
clauses so if any future development of
the car park was to be desired by the
council we would have an ability to
break that lease and then continue on
with our plans as a council
and we would make sure that's negotiated
and with with new orders as appropriate
thank you further questions appear to be
none we have a recommendation as someone
happy to
or prepared to move it joan moved by
jones
seconded by morris joan do you wish to
speak to
no it sounds pretty reasonable to me
morris i'd say degree sounds
quite a reasonable idea for me to have
so you should go
with it any any other speakers
right i'll put the recommendation sorry
is that
jason sorry um i forgot to clear but i
might be slightly compromising this so
might i abstain
we'll notifilate it
my apologies that's all right i'll put
the recommendation
all those in favor please say hi to the
country
carried you can tell your boss you voted
against it
right item 6.4
update of community board standing
orders sarah uh
pages 88 to 166.
who's dealing with that okay
right yep um good evening everyone
uh this report is basically just
formalizing what we have been doing for
the last couple of months
um and including the ability
for boards to meet electronically or
through technical means
or if a member is unable to attend a
meeting for
any reason and desperately wants to talk
at the meeting
they are able to um come in through
technical abilities so that's the only
real change in these
new standing orders um
just making official the ability to use
platforms like zoom and
team teams and various and sunday other
items
um i'll take the the report is read and
i will answer any questions
any questions i've got one for you
okay the report is silent
on a code of conduct committee
as i understand it uh this actually came
up last night so
i'm hoping i can answer you um
the code of conduct if
each board already has a code of conduct
so if there is a desire
for the board to um
look at a problem and require the
use of a code of conduct committee the
first item they would need to do is
create a code of conduct committee and
then
once they've done that they will then
have to use that kind of conduct
committee to deal with the matter at
hand
there's no reason there's no expectation
that the code of conduct
committee need be made up of board
members
if they don't wish to they could refer
the matter to the council's code of
conduct committee
there are various summary reasons and
methods of dealing with something like
that
but in this particular
document they're leaving it to be
discussed
as and when it is required
okay any other questions duncan
page 119
9.11 k or perhaps jim yourself since
you've been mia
withdraw of an agenda item
is that a very common occurrence
because obviously we would probably
pride ourselves on with pretty bit lazy
at times the board members
generating their own agenda or
generating their items but
under what circumstance would a ceo
remove an agenda item
well normally with the community board
perspective
if there was an item on the agenda and
for whatever reason
the staff weren't quite ready to proceed
and needed more information
it could be with experience withdrawn
for that basis
and the chair clearly would agree yes i
don't know of any other
reason it's usually used if
other information comes up after the
report has been signed off
and that information could impact on
the recommendations or or
there's something that maybe has been
left out of the report that
the report writer feels the members
really ought to know
that's often when an item is removed and
then
brought forward to the next meeting
just to maybe help with some context
around that so
you're probably aware management team
get to review the report
so the reason it's quite rare is because
of
any issues of that kind of nature that
get brought up
are normally caught before they end up
getting onto either a council or a
community board
agenda so it would be in really rare
circumstances that that would probably
happen yes
any other questions okay
i've actually been gone right through it
which
might surprise you and i found that it
tidied up some messes of the
that had been created particularly in
the right of reply area where
uh it had been changed in the last
council that a
mover of an amendment had a right to
reply so the chair is the time
thought and that's been tidied up so i
think it's
it's a bit loose with the code of
conduct in my view but that's another
issue
no other questions someone prepared to
move something
moved by paul segment by robbie
we should speak to it no robbie
all right i'll put that all those in
favor please say
the country clear carried
right now we come to item 6.5
on pages 167 to 169 that's on the quarry
okay
um this is an item that you're all very
familiar with at the moment
and due to the fact that there is some
uncertainty of
when this item will be when the quality
application will be notified um
given that it's usually only 20 days if
it happens just prior to your board
meeting you might
you might be a bit caught for time
so a request came through
from both the chair and
matt bacon saying that to make sure that
we had recovered that eventuality
that this report be written in basically
allowing
the chair and two other people to
compose
the um the submission with the help of
an expert obviously it would be
circulated prior to it being lodged
informally and then brought to the
following
meeting to be ratified
that's just it's belt embraces because
if there is plenty of time
you probably might not need this just up
to you
now there is a change in recommendation
for you i just read it carefully
a receives a report b this is a new
b delegates authority to the chairperson
board member some and so board member
so-and-so
to work with an appropriately qualified
advisor
to submit the board submission and
opposition on resource consent
and see that the board's submission be
submitted to a subsequent
meeting or is the alternative we oppose
you don't make one so
i'll hand this to you you know so that's
quite a late change
but we will need some assistance here
and so that's why i brought forward the
change to
to work with an appropriate qualified
advisor
morris what is a qualified advisor is
that a staff member or someone outside
look can we take it as
in committee we're not in committee i
didn't want to go down this road at this
stage
but it'll be someone that